the time being 9 30 i like to call this
meeting
of the long-range planning and
utilization committee to order
first i'd like to tell the members of
the committee
that this is being live streamed to the
best of my knowledge so that if you
speak if you could just press the
um button
the red will show up i can mute you all
if i want
but
it does go out
and it's the only way that it will go
out and be picked up is if you use some
microphones
second
alternate
house member
representative edgar is filling in
for representative mcconkey
and the chair declares that a quorum is
first item of business is the acceptance
of the minutes of the november 9th 2021
meeting do i hear a motion
senator d'alessandro moose approval
seconded by
representative edgar
any discussion
seeing none all those in favor signify
by saying aye aye
opposed nay
the ice have it and the minutes are
accepted
we have no old business
new business
um
rsa 439 b approval of state agency
leases exceeding five years
um
if somebody from the department is here
to speak about
lrcp
22-01 department of safety
requests approval of a 10-year lease
agreement with one wall street llc
and brickwater llc care of brady
sullivan properties llc
670 north commercial street suite 303
manchester new hampshire for
approximately 4 900 square feet of space
for the division of motor vehicles
located on the second floor of 377 south
willow street manchester commons
manchester new hampshire effective april
1st 2022
through march 31st 2032
for the amount not to exceed 988
thousand 820 dollars subject to the
schedule of annual rent and conditions
as specified in the request
and will
the department is here to talk about
this
good morning mr chair members of the
committee steve lavoy director of
administration for the department of
safety and with me is jeff bond the
assistant director of the division of
motor vehicles
so before you today we do have this item
to request authorization to enter into a
10-year lease agreement for the dmv
substation in manchester new hampshire
that's located on 377 south willow
street
this location has 4 900 square feet of
commercial space that meets all the
needs of the dmv
there's a large customer lobby area
area for staff climate controlled data
closet ada compliant
secure storage area and there's also
sufficient parking and the ability for
the dmv to provide some
driver exam licensing activities in that
in that area
the department did request and obtain a
waiver from
the department of administrative
services
to waive admin rule 6106
so this would be a sole source
arrangement and the waiver was requested
because again as i mentioned this
location meets all the needs of the dmv
but we also had a very
good negotiation with the existing
landlord so that the square footage
price went from 13.25 to 13.45
per square foot
we also if uh
without going out to bid that helps us
to avoid the additional cost of a fit up
for a new location if the if the
location were to change and that's a
significant cost savings staying in the
current location
that's the item that's before you today
and would be happy to answer any
questions that you may have
questions from members of the committee
see none what is the will of the
committee
senator d'alessandro moves approval of
lrcp
22-001 is our second representative
edgar seconds the motion
any discussion on the motion before us
seeing none all those in favor signify
by saying aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
approved
the chair would like to specify that
representative jess edwards
will be filling in for representative
mills
i i apologize for my delay i was
testifying on hb 1665.
i'd have been more worried if i didn't
moving on
to rsa 439c disposal of highway or
turnpike funded real estate
first item is lrcp 21-0
department of transportation
authorized to sell approximately 22 plus
or minus acres of state-owned land
within the controlled access
right-of-way
located on the westerly side of route 11
mount major highway in the town of alton
directly to the society for the
protection of new hampshire forces for
181 thousand one hundred dollars which
includes a one thousand one hundred
dollar administrative fee subject to the
conditions as specified in the request
the department is here
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i'm steve labonte i'm the
administrator of the bureau of right of
way with new hampshire department of
transportation
the parcel the subject parcel is at the
base of mount major and encompasses the
parking lot
that serves the hiking trails
it was originally purchased in
1968 for 2 900
and that was a the total
uh parcel was um complete parcel was 43
43.53
acres
uh as a condition of the sale
the society will have to
have a licensed land surveyor do a
right-of-way adjustment plan and we'll
be maintaining 125 foot right-of-way
off-center
line they'll also have to if they can
build any structures any greater than
200 feet above ground level they'll need
requirements from
the faa because of the
air
the airport on
alton bay during the winter
um there is some restrictive covenants
that will go along with this
regarding an old cemetery that was
discovered on the site and the appraised
value was
a hundred and eighty thousand plus as
earlier mentioned they'll be assessed a
1100 administrative fee i'm happy to
take questions if there are any
questions from
members of the committee on this item to
the department
senator alessandra
what what did we purchase it for
initially
i believe it was purchased for the route
11 project
but
that's what i'd have to guess
okay and you said the purchase price was
correct
further questions
representative edward
thank you mr chair so uh i'm just
curious um who
what kind of an entity would be
interested in purchasing this parking
lot because it sounds like it's
primarily a parking lot and and what
what sort of purpose might they put it
to
my understanding is what they're going
to do is expand the existing parking lot
if you've ever gone by mount major in
the summertime you'll see cars lined up
along route 11 because the parking lot
there just isn't big enough
to serve all the hikers that
hike mount major so
they plan to expand the parking lot
follow-up
so in order to have the capital to
expand the parking lot uh should we
imagine that they're gonna start to
charge parking fees
and and and if so that would be
makes sense but what sort of parking fee
structure do you have any clue this is
premature i know
i'm not aware i don't know if they're
any further questions from members of
the committee
saying none what is the will of the
senator d'alessandro moves approval of
lrcp
21-03
seconded by
senator birzel
is there any discussion on this item
see none all those in favor of the
motion to approve the item signify by
saying aye aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it and item lrcp
item lrcp 22-002
department of transportation
authorization to sell 0.65 plus a minus
of an acre of state-owned land located
at the intersection of black hall road
and new hampshire route 4 in the town of
epson directly to thomas leclerc
in the amount of fifty thousand dollar
and assess an administrative fee of one
thousand one hundred dollars pursuant to
rsa 440
3-a
subject to the conditions as specified
thank you mr chairman the original
parcel um was as complete was one acre
improved with a residential dwelling on
it
we purchased it
back in 1994 for 99 500
the parcel will be conveyed with no
access to route 4.
buyer will have to submit a lot line
adjustment completed by a licensed land
surveyor
and the appraised contributory value
to the
a budding parcel the there's no
development potential so there's really
no market for this parcel other than to
the abutter was 50 000
plus an administrative an 1100
administrative fee
i'm happy to take questions if there are
any questions to the department from
we purchased an acre-sized parcel with a
residential dwelling for ninety nine
okay thank you thank you so so the
residential dwelling was demolished
correct
okay
and
what did what did that do to the value
of the property the fact that you didn't
have a full moon or well it
it
we did it to to widen the the person
reason for buying it was
for a transportation project so we ended
up
taking i i would say about a third of an
acre off of it
plus demolished the residential dwelling
and now there's no um there's
the only value to it is contributory
value to the abutting parcel because
it's i don't believe it has any
development potential
so of of the original if i'm not mr so
of the original purpose
what what's left
we're moving we're moving a piece but
the 0.65 plus or minus and we purchased
an acre yeah where we purchased an acre
we widened the road now we're going to
sell the remnant which is
six five plus or minus of an x so we we
used about if i might we used about a
third of an acre correct all right we
demolished the house
correct we paid ninety to eight thousand
five hundred dollars correct and we're
moving what we have left for fifty
thousand dollars
correct
would one consider that a good business
practice
if you're in the business of building
okay would you thank you we're not in
the business of re we're not real estate
thank you
but
just just for clarification is it not
the policy of the department
to try to to purchase the small sliver
that may be needed to widen the road and
if those negotiations fail take the
purchase the entire property
uh rather than going through a domain
and the rest
what we would purchase the tire in the
entire property if we're going to leave
a non-economic remnant so basically if
the strip we're going to take is
other than contributory value to your
butter that then we would do a complete
acquisition
see
representative edwards
this is a on the previous item i may i
may i just ask that when you get further
down the road and you start to figure
out who's going to purchase this and
what they're going to do with parking
fee assessments if you it's being sold
directly to the society for the
i hadn't heard that answer when i asked
okay thank you
okay back to item
senator the bird cell moves to approve
uh representative clutier seconds the
see none
all those in favor of approval of item
22-0
[Music]
say aye
opposed nay
one nay the eyes
prevail and the item is approved
moving on to lrcp 22-03
department of transportation
authorized authorization to dispose of
1.89 plus or minus acres of state-owned
land with improvements located at 1556
white mountain highway in the town of
madison by entering into a listing
agreement for the term of one year with
caldwell banker lifestyles for the sale
price of 279 000
and assess an administrative fee of 1
pursuant to rsa 443-a
allowing negotiations within the
committee's current policy guidelines
subject to the conditions that are
specified in the request
thank you mr chairman the parcel is
improved with a residential dwelling and
a garage
we are going to list it at
279 000 plus the 1100 administrative fee
the parcel was purchased in 2005 for 225
thousand dollars
the
department will maintain a 50-foot
right-of-way off-center line and the
buyer will be responsible
to
submit a lot line adjustment plan
completed by a licensed land surveyor
can take questions
i i do have one
um
assuming that we do sell
make this sale
will that money go
back into trying to pay back what we owe
the federal government on the the
conway bypass
yes this is an
ineligible property so we'll go toward
the payback
thank you
further questions from members of the
seeing none what is the pleasure of the
representative edgar moves to approve
senator byrd still seconds
is there any further discussion on this
item
see none
all those in favor of the motion to
approve
22-003 signify by saying aye aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
moving on to rsa 440 disposal of real
estate
good morning chairman members of the
committee my name is betsy mcnaughton
i'm a land agent for fish and game
thank you
lrcp 21-039
new hampshire fish and game department
requests approval of the relocation and
modification of two state-owned
easements over property owned by lcj
holdings llc
and
that provide access to the state-owned
pembroke
panhandle
manager area nobody laugh come to new
hampshire and assess an administrative
fee of one thousand one hundred dollars
pursuant to rsa 443a
subject to the conditions as specified
in the request and the department is
so this um
particular
parcel was um has actually the
representative from d.o.t explained was
a the wildlife management area was a
remnant after um in a non-um accessible
lot
after um i-93 was or not yeah i-93 was
built through camden and thornton
and um the history of this property of
the wildlife management area and access
to it
um
is is a little colorful as i tried to
explain in the letter
uh
the original owner of the remnant lot
which became the wildlife management
area and the east side lot on the east
side of 93 there was it was the same
owner so the access to that
farm lot was through a farm field
but when that lot was sold the east side
lot was sold
there was an agreement between the
landowner and new hampshire fish and
game to provide access to the wildlife
management area for hunters
and that worked out well for several
years
except when the um
the farmer sold to uh al's nest golf
course which was um
i think originally al street associates
and when they built the the
the golf course
they had to renegotiate the hunters
access across that property
so the original access in your packet
there's there should be a color-coded
plan
that shows i hope everyone got has the
color version of this
the access that was negotiated was both
the the pink and the green
and the pink version is was the public
access along with a parking area a
little bit down the street from al
street
and
that's a little bit of a long access
across a property um
for hunters to use
and
it was rarely used actually by hunters
the green
section of that plan was the fish and
game management access
um
the which is a much more reasonable
access we would take brush hogs across
the um across that access to go and do
habitat management work on the wildlife
management area
the
[Music]
when al street
fell into bankruptcy
lcj purchased the property
and when they purchased the property
after a year or two they they made some
changes to the golf course without
notifying us of these changes
that they were making which altered our
access
and
so this is uh after
quite a bit of um
conversations negotiations discussions
you know on-site meetings um we came up
with um a plan
because they were in violation of the
original easement that the maintenance
access
agreement sorry maintenance maintenance
access easement that is the green on
your plan
b both
the maintenance and the public access
which would eliminate the pink on on
makes it a much better
um
access for hunters and it they they are
providing a parking area
which
was eliminated
by
a street being developed
so there were multiple violations so
through the negotiations
we came up with this solution and so
we're releasing the pink part of the
plan
and gaining public access over the green
section which is also our management
access it's a much better solution
to what was originally there
and i'm happy to take any questions it's
a little complicated i understand it's
the map helped
um
questions from members of the committee
senator del sandov
thank you mr chairman
so
if i'm to understand what you just said
it's owl's nest that violated the
covenant
it's lcj ltj yes the company who owns
the owl's nest golf course right okay so
there i have relatives that live in
campton on eldrith hill road yes so
so they violated
the covenant which which indeed
i'm told that they had a habit of doing
um this was our only experience with
them with lcj um with al's nest
we had a different relationship with the
owner of the owl's nest or al street
associates
but he's
he's not in the picture he's good
he's out of the picture as we speak okay
would further question
thank you
so this solves the problem
okay we have act we have yes access
and um
have there been any other violations
that we have uncovered at this point no
not that we're we have seen um
we go out to the wild the pemmy wildlife
management area on the west side every
couple of years due to brush hogging
our conservation officers are out there
every once in a while to go and
take care of hunting issues that happen
on the wildlife management area but this
is the
this is the only one that i'm aware of
um
the previous owner we've um we've had
violations with the previous owner but
that's he's gone
and um and i just think this is a much
better solution even though they were in
violation and it really
we were a little surprised by it i i
think the end result is so much better
for the hunters
that want to access the property great
great it it's great that we solved the
problem
one further question now what about the
rest of the development that's now
taking place in that area there's a
there's a great deal of development up
on the hill
uh we're not involved in that at all are
you talking about on the on farther east
on the like behind the clubhouse and
yeah yeah behind the clubhouse
and over there that they're going to
create a reservoir or some of something
of that yeah
and they're building all of those homes
yes
um they're they we have not
they are they're not affecting the
wildlife management area
so and they're not abutting it so i
haven't been following it i'm aware that
the the building has been going on since
the um previous owner's days
would further questions but one more
we are changing the scope of the land
though
yes but i'm not i i haven't been out
there i haven't looked at that that's
not um
what my focus is okay
thank you thank you thank you
welcome
obviously you've been in discussions
with the uh the holding company they
understand that they're gonna owe us
eleven hundred dollars
thank you any further questions from
saying none what is the will of the
committee
senator d'alessandro moves the item
[Music]
21-0-3-9 seconded by senator byrdsall
any further discussion on this item
let the records show that senator gaida
has shown in his present for the vote on
this this item
um all those in favor signify by saying
aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and the
motion is approved
chairman may i ask a question
certainly
how uh and it was asked of me um how
does the 1100
um
administrative fee
is it in through invoice is it through
something just a it's the order through
i will leave that to the
right so i think you'd want to work with
administrative services to see the
process that you should use for that
um and depending on the
source of the funds would depend where
the money ends up
being deposited so it may end up back in
the fish and game if you use the fish
and game fund to purchase that property
back in the day yes it would go back
back in the fish and game fund yes so is
there anybody at administrative services
i talked to your business supervisor to
get guidance on that i think she's the
one actually who asked me because we
don't we very rarely do this
yeah reach out to me after and i can
work with you on that thank you very
much
that was our last action item
there were two informational items that
were included lrcp
is there any questions or discussion on
the two informational items
seeing none
i would propose that our next meeting
be held march monday march 28th
that is after
um
after all action has to be completed
on bills
and reporting
to at least on the house side i don't
never speak for the senate um but
crossover is the 31st of march
thursday the 31st so all bills should
already have been filed
for for action
by that monday i would hope
so i would propose that we meet that
monday morning at 9 30
if there's
no objection from the members of the
monday march 28th i believe it is
is there any further business that we
need to conduct for long range planning
c9 i thank everybody for coming
i appreciate it um
and for those who are who are following
on live stream it sounds like we will go
quickly but all the members of the
committee have had all of this
information at least a week before and
have been able to read through it and
and do it so sometimes it looks like
we're just running quickly but
we've done our due diligence homework
beforehand thank you all and
you